welcome to this video playing Papua 29
well I have a good score against this
crap it's nice probably not one of six
yeah trying to play quicker yeah my Jack
my great concept now mm-hmm
okay let's see putting the night here on
e4 can I go f5 hmm
sometimes d5 is an issue with that I
never know that's just okay I cannot
take off I cannot take on g2 anyway
oh is castling long now that's that's
interesting so let's see I cannot guess
what short anyway as aged seven hangs
maybe I should go long as well why not
interesting tries to trade off my bishop
here hmm it's d5 an idea or not at least
he cannot take two or take because III
hangs okay it looks like a slightly more
interesting way to play then than other
moves let's see if I can maybe play e5
this was my idea actually yeah why not
five leading to an interesting position
maybe I can just take on d4 and c4 and
then have a very weird iqp position
where hand both sides have casted long
okay so he probably after taking on d4
wants to play a form very very
interesting idea the good one probably
yeah not much that I can do about it
Knight c5 I thought and then c6 one
Knight e5 and then c6 complicated stuff
if I go c5 takes Knight takes ships e5
maybe coming okay maybe I can also take
with the bishop if he takes bishop takes
with the idea to play em Bishop a4 at
some point yeah maybe
therefore I can take d3 that's that's
definitely okay a c4 hang so and Bishop
a4 is a threat now that G I think needs
to attend to
it's very annoying pin bishop a form no
it's not reacting so isn't this so
annoying or am i yeah let's play that
let's play it yeah when I was three
thinking that rook c8 or something is
just now a problem isn't it why isn't
this a big problem I don't know
he's just giving up the Queen young
probably it was this is necessary taking
here rook takes Bishop b3 so he has to
take with the mind jacket so check check
check to cover c6 no probably grab stuff
use the active Queen okay probably let's
take away some squares from the Knighton
Knight to Queen to e5 or something as
this looks good centralizing maybe Roxy
for now Roxy form to a tacit Knight f3
queen is 6 4 for discovery yeah maybe
it's 95 about the Queen e7 it's not not
a big problem
I want to try to not to fall too much
behind on the clock iam and I'm I'm
taking I'm threatening to take you as
well okay Queenie seven simply if he
takes on age seven this this night has
no square just age six or is the
drawback age six and grab on e4 no let's
just take that okay so he wants to give
some checks iam queen is six for the pin
can check here but I can go Group C for
as well so that I can so that I can
interpose check yeah this is made
checkmate
yeah he'd simply ignored to Bishop a4
which I really think this was a threat
like here Bishop a4 is the threat and he
didn't do anything against it so Bishop
a6 is the computer suggestion with the
slide edge to black I'm getting getting
bigger now likes edge I wasn't really
sure what's going on but I'm sure that
now we have Bishop a4 wins it's just a
flat-out win because this is a deadly
pin he cannot get out of it and for
Queen e6 is even stronger according to
the combat it wins it wins the Queen so
why why not check check yeah and black
black just wins here I'm not sure about
the sequence before it was interesting
c5 was also coming into consideration
but I liked the look of a 5 however this
idea I didn't see beforehand here and
now the computer wants to play Knight C
form not this move Knight c4 I am and
the computer gives this with an edge too
wide
yeah possible this is problem is blocked
and white has a good center I have g5 as
an interesting way to try to break it
yeah that gives 0.62 wide yeah what's
better time very possibly much possible
but it didn't happen he played this
takes takes yeah and this Bishop a4 idea
already gives black a good game and
after ignoring it widest lost simply
yeah it was an interesting interesting
type of position yeah with both sides
getting long ok I hope you enjoyed it
thanks for watching